[Musik]
es ist schon habe ich 60 bin nicht im
stadion
er muss mindestens 72 stunden vorher im
stadium der ganztag schnitt so schön ich
danke das relativ günstiges hobby was
ich sage
[Musik]
anna montanaro leidet an einer besonders
aggressiven form der multiplen sklerose
über ein jahr lang haben wir sie
begleitet mit 18 bekannt sie die völlig
überraschende diagnose ms
bis dahin war die lebensfrohe luana
sportlich aktiv und erfolgreich im
tennis war sie in ihrer alterskategorie
die nummer zwei des nationalkaders
und sie spielte fußball beim
zweitligisten fc spiez
doch seit neun jahren ist johannes
alltag radikal eingeschränkt
wenn die rohstoffe wahn im bett die
musik nach da lag so spaß die grafiker
haben dass das mache ich so und da ist
er ja das ist eine handpuppe stiefel
wenn ich die ganze zeit machen also
macht unbewusst und die szene machte sie
eben wo der region etwa machen und die
muss ich dabei bin natürlich auch in
weiteren tank nicht bewegen damit sie
dort eigentlich vorhanden
janika des milliarden
verstehst du hast den erschienen auf dem
nachttisch lieder medikament wie viel da
pleite mussten 44
und wieso musst du mit der kraft der
sonne und das ganze mit nimmt seine
editor cisco heroin abhängig gemacht
oder körperlich extrem schnell abhängig
von dem ziel also wenn ich jetzt mal weg
kritisierte toni tomic es ist wirklich
schlimm
fazit wer schmerzen weiter mit der
schweizer schlägt also sich sehr
beängstigend dass merkel wie auch nicht
im kopf aber wie abhängig die chronisch
aber ich weiß das ist nicht angst
komische segen und fluch zugleich
die fachmittelschule musste sie kurz vor
schluss abbrechen
psychologin wollte sie werden anderen
menschen helfen
sie lebt zusammen mit ihrer mutter karin
und ihrer jüngeren schwester vivien
[Musik]
multiple sklerose ist eine chronische
nervenerkrankung die das gehirn und das
rückenmark betrifft bei johanna
aggressiver ms sind viele
körperfunktionen betroffen erblindung
auf dem linken auge
lähmungserscheinungen an den beinen
starke schmerzen blasen und
darmstörungen und darum sie mir nach
konzentrieren und öfter wegen der
täglichen kortison tabletten hat luana
stark an gewicht zugelegt auf das
einzige ms medikament das wirklich
helfen würde ist hier allergisch
euro favorit die zweite johannes
geschwächtes immunsystem produziert kaum
antikörper und ein ms medikament hat bei
ihr zusätzlich eine blutkrankheit
ausgelöst es ist kompliziert mit
christoph sauer und die zerstörer hat
aus und jetzt muss sie auch zwei wochen
die therapie co und immunglobulin a und
zusätzlich habe die therapie eigentlich
hauptsächlich für patienten die
musikschule das ist wir haben uns
patienten nach 1000 m in die zweite
woche hier
es macht mich nervös und irgendwie
schlechter die tatsache dass machen kam
aus china
valascia
[Musik]
mutter karin arbeitet nur noch einen
halben tag pro woche und juliana da zu
sein
normalerweise würde luana nach dieser
behandlung komplett erschöpft nach hause
gehen
doch heute spielt ihr geliebter fc thun
luana und ein spiel verpassen geht gar
nicht
franke erster macht ja
was heißt ein vorbereiter zur fahrer
arbeite das team jetzt minute
ich sage gerne zeigt die familie und das
ist wie mit dem außer dem anspruch der
luft zum atmen dass kalla luft und für
das was sie von mir machen sich einfach
grandios
michael schmitz und eine durch den
wandel
die clique aus
sie schieben hilfe mit sing mit mir geht
es nicht ohne sie geht es nicht zu tun
genau
vor dem spiel schick luana oft eine
motivation brief an ihren lieblingsklub
liebe jungs meine blutwerte haben sich
drastisch verschlechtert das bedeutet
nun jede zweite woche leidet trifft den
heutigen tag
aber trotz neun stunden zimmer komme ich
natürlich an spiel will auch
unterstützen wenn es manchmal
aussichtslos erscheint dann rate ich
mein liebefeld gibt niemals deine
hoffnung auf wie es auch kommt im
lebenslauf
denn wenn du denkst es geht nicht mehr
kommt irgendwo eigentlich daher und gibt
die mut kraft und vertrauen dem
schicksal was aufs maul zu hauen
zweimal habe zu einer säge plötzlich
euro maskottchen
[Applaus]
das stadion ist du als kraftort
durch zeigt am ende bist spürst die
nicht mehr zu weniger
ich hoffe meine geschwister vermittelt
werden
[Musik]
es ist ein derby spielt 2018 der fc thun
gegen die berner young boys thun darf
nicht verlieren sonst droht der
abstiegskampf
die nächste
[Musik]
hmm
[Applaus]
kein geld
[Musik]
[Applaus]
nein
[Musik]
unentschieden aufatmen
[Applaus]
mehr
[Musik]
die gäste
bedachte bewältigen
da sachsen
[Applaus]
hk
wenig lohnen
[Musik]
[Gelächter]
wo
drei monate später
johanna ist in der reha klinik basel wo
sie immer wieder kämpft ihre noch
verbleibenden kräfte zu erhalten
johanna möchte so lange wie möglich
bleiben doch gerade hat dir das
therapeutenteam bei der visite
mitgeteilt dass sie nach vier wochen
nach hause muss hier unter anderem
patienten fühlt sie sich verstanden hat
nicht wie zu hause das gefühl für
familie und freunde eine belastung zu
sein
johannas therapeut motiviert sie
spielerisch zum muskelaufbau was leicht
aussieht erfordert an ihre kräfte
[Musik]
sehr schön
russen polen holt
okay okay
ok also allein stehen ist eine riesen
anstrengung
jawohl das ist das doch machen und
handwerk das gerät einwandfrei und hätte
ohne sitze ist super und sehr gut
das ziel ist klar doch dass es sehr wohl
über also am 1
[Musik]
wasser ist magie für johanna hier
verwandelt sich die unerträglichkeit des
schicksals kurz in einer
schwerelosigkeit des 1
[Musik]
das reha team hat entschieden dass
johanna bereits nach vier wochen die
gesteckten therapieziele erreicht hat
[Musik]
der ball da geht einiges besser sie
vergisst was sie eigentlich nicht und
sie merkt am schluss was sie eigentlich
eine leichte und das aber das schöne und
da erwarte mir dass die fichte genauso
viel freude an das schwimmbad oder dass
sie mal etwas probiert wiesdorf wie
unsere
[Musik]
vier monate später
luana hat einen schlimmen rückfall und
ist auf einem tiefpunkt sinnlos und
ausgang nimmt
das ist ja so dass bc schlechte geld und
es ist aussteigen will und so im
rollstuhl und somit schweiz bin ohne
gott
die aktion war er mit familie und
freunde ja das tun aber das ist im
moment 15 minuten 20 schwarz
du hast dich bicsi tag molde warum
[Applaus]
sehr oft
sehr stark gesunken
das belegen wie in wüste steppe
bettlägerig und blind zu werden nicht
mehr sprechen zu können ist das größte
angst
[Musik]
johanna ist wieder im reha
dieses mal darf sie neun wochen bleiben
nach ihrem tief hat sie von einer
stammzelltherapie gehört und möchte
unbedingt ins programm aufgenommen
werden wieder droht dem fc thun der
abstieg aber auch an schlechten club
zeiten schöpft loana von ihren kickern
kraft die stammzelltransplantation habe
dinge dass sie eventuell zu lassen und
eine der 50 meter lauf und das ist ein
sport die zweite bedingung ist
und da man jetzt selber kilo ab und
probiert es eben mehr und über dinge die
ich an ihn nicht geschlossen und das ist
das wahr machen und welche studie ist
wenn sie natürlich riesig deshalb bis
passiert wie möglich halten
[Musik]
sieben mal umfallen acht mal aufstehen
das ist lulas fußball und lebensmotto ja
[Musik]
was auffällig von daher wo sie klopft
ohne ball wo man zum stuhl dafür sind
nicht mehr ganz sicher kommt sie wieder
extreme fokus o für die ataxie oft
spastik was nicht gut sind
wahrscheinlich am 20
da kann ich meine bodychecks casey jean
botti kate ich wieder aufgestanden
einfach auf fröhlich wie es aussieht
ohne überhaupt danke das überhaupt
[Musik]
prinzip hoffnung in schwarz chef nick
reilly hatte das fest und wie schnell
der lust
die kosten
plötzlich
ok
[Musik]
links